and now we're going to go to brett baer
fox news chief political anchor
brett uh we'll get your thoughts on the
primaries first and then we'll go to the
horrific tragedy uh in texas but what
are you seeing so far in these primary
races any surprises
not a ton of surprises but just let's
bounce around a little bit uh the
governor's races first georgia it was
not even close uh with kemp taking this
in fact look at these counties these are
all kemp counties it's not clear that
purdue is going to win a single county
here uh you heard i should mention the
race in alabama it does appear that ivy
is moving forward but whether she gets
over that 50 mark that is a real
question
let's go out here to
the house races you just uh heard about
the house race in texas congressional
district 28 this is a big deal for
cisneros who's the progressive uh to be
up like this we've got 77 percent in
quay arm a moderate uh well liked in the
district but they the progressives went
after him so uh the squad i'm talking
aoc uh
rashida talib bernie sanders went out
there cuellar is one of if not the last
in the house
pro-life democrat
and he's at risk of possibly losing this
particular race and then as we take a
look at the senate races it wasn't even
close
here for herschel walker that is a walk
he goes now up against rafael warnock
which should be an interesting race
to say the least
you have the update in pennsylvania
which is fascinating we are still at
roughly you know just under a thousand
votes with mehmed oz leading and as of
tonight
all of the counties are said to be in
and there are some provisional ballots
there are a few military ballots but it
does not appear to be anywhere close to
the number that mccormick would need to
overturn that now the recount point five
percent it's allowed it's triggered but
mccormick could concede before that out
of the last six recounts in the state of
pennsylvania statewide three were waived
off by the opponent said no you don't
have to do it three who that went
forward uh increased the lead for the
person going in so cost about 1.5
million dollars to do the recount we'll
see what happens in pennsylvania uh in
probably a couple days
lauren
brett the um the news that
i guess it's not all that surprising
that texas attorney general's race
uh nbc news other outlets i guess we're
also reporting now that uh george p bush
is the first bush i guess to lose
statewide office
ever
in texas to ken pax and again the bush
star power is still very strong in texas
but paxton was able to hold off that
challenge
yeah and he was endorsed by former
president trump uh paxton kind of won
that easily over george p bush who was
the land commissioner in texas the other
surprising one went the other way it
looks like in georgia the secretary of
state brad raffensberger is going to win
that contest not over yet but it looks
like it's heading that way
and he obviously was targeted by the
former president
who supported his uh his opponent so
it's a mixed bag tonight but overall
former president trump still obviously
has a big lead as far as his
endorsements and win losses tonight's
big loss though was obviously georgia
where the incumbent brian camp went on
to win
and the secretary of state
lost that's a that's a big one as well
but i think you're right on the left on
the ledger it goes the other way all
right brett thank you great to see you
tonight hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else